[Applause]
as one of gymnastics all-time greats
simone biles has repeatedly demonstrated
her determination and sporting
excellence
a different aspect of that strong
character has been in evidence during
these olympics
first withdrawing in the early stages of
the women's team final
and then pulling out of her next gold
medal competition on thursday
biles instead choosing to prioritize her
mental health
i was just like shaking could barely nap
i just
never felt like this going into a
competition before
and i tried to go out here and have fun
and warm up in the back went a little
bit better but then once i came out here
i was like
no mental is not there so i just need to
let the girls do it and focus on myself
all athletes arriving at these delayed
olympics faced unique external pressures
from dealing with unprecedented levels
of social media scrutiny
to the fear of a positive kovid 19 test
biles had also set herself the task of
becoming the first
female gymnast to win five gold medals
at a single games
the athlete normally doesn't have a
voice nor does an athlete
trust their voice she not only has a
voice which i love but she also trusts
her voice and she knows she's going to
get a little bit of backlash
from fans and you know people are like
how could you let your team down
or whatever but the best thing she can
do is shut off
all this outside chatter anything that's
not coming from her own head or from her
support system
need not need not be heard earlier this
year japan's sporting
superstar nomi osaka took a two-month
break from playing
top-level tennis she said she no longer
wanted to do press conferences
in order to protect her mental health
she also admitted
to having prolonged bouts of depression
ever since winning her first grand slam
title
in 2018 it brought a temporary halt to
her career
but did start an important conversation
in her home country i think
in japan we don't we still don't talk
about mental health
and when naomi osaka came out with the
issue
there's been lots of comments negative
comments on her
and i believe that was also kind of
exaggerated with the gender
issue after her unexpected loss at
these games osaka admitted to feeling
weighed down by the pressure
of playing in a home olympics biles may
yet compete in next week's individual
event finals
regardless this pair of champion
athletes are leading the way
in showing the world it is okay to talk
about mental lows
as well as sporting highs
now let's go back to andy richardson who
joins us once again from tokyo and andy
what's been the response from athletes
competing in tokyo
i think it's been really telling i think
in the past if an athlete had pulled out
of an event like this
she may have expected to have received a
lot of criticism the overwhelming
uh sentiment towards simone biles has
been one of support from athletes around
the world and also from within
uh the us olympic team let's have a
listen to what some of her
olympic teammates have had to say
i really hope that she continues to do
what's best for her and that
the people around her her coaches her
teammates continue to support her
i know that the team usa swimmers
certainly support her and
the the us gymnastics team and and all
of our teammates
um you know and and mental health is so
important
at the end of the day so many little
people understand the struggles of
an elite athlete let alone an athlete
like simone biles who's at the top of
her
training range and she is the curve
she's
literally her own bar and i don't think
people
fail people fail to recognize that she
is also a human being